hello and welcome to the take with
Sophie rage live at nine here in the
heart of Westminster now it's our first
take of the new year but really the same
story there's another ambulance strike
today with more nurse walkouts due next
week and doctors about saying right now
for their own industrial action all of
that in a Health Service that does seem
on the brink meanwhile one rail Union
boss but the chances of a deal that
would call their strike action off
zero so we'll be talking to one man at
the center of the dispute the transport
secretary plus will have an exclusive
interview with the head of the nurses
Union and takes from all sides over the
next 60 minutes
his response to the greatest crisis in
the history of the NHS is to threaten to
sack our nurses well Kirsten pretty
clear there who he blames for the
strikes in the HS but Rishi sunak said
they were a risk to the public
what's terrifying is that right now
people not knowing whether when they
call 999 they will get the treatment
that they need
meanwhile the Scottish national party
wanted to focus on the special
investigation by Sky News into money in
Westminster and called for reform of the
system
let's reflect upon numbers and in
particular those numbers which were
shown away on by Sam Coates of sky
well we'll bring you that call for
Change and the latest of our special
reports from the Westminster accounts
and we're going to be focusing on the
NHS with our viewers panel as we try and
find out more about the state of the
health service across the UK you can see
them all there we'll be talking to them
a little bit later for their takes plus
we'll have exactly the interviews that
you need to hear this evening with the
transport secretary Mark Harper
the General Secretary of the Royal
College of Nursing Pat Cullen will be
here with us and the shadow transport
secretary 2 Louise Hay plus much more
besides on the take
[Applause]
[Music]
hello good evening it's an absolutely
packed show this evening I don't know
how we're going to fit it all in but
we're going to be focusing on the
strikes that we've been discussing plus
we'll bring you the very latest on the
big project here at Sky News bringing
greater transparency to money in
Westminster that was given top billing
by the SMP at Primus questions today the
party says there must be route and
Branch reform well let's start though
with the best bits of the week so far
Sky News and tortoise media have
launched the Westminster accounts which
is a major project designed to shine a
light on how money flows into politics
over 17 million pounds that's the total
amount of outside earnings that MPS have
declared in the course of this
Parliament you know the more
transparency the better I think
transparency is really important do you
think that it is helpful to pull all
this stuff together yes in one database
yes we're talking about the the elite of
the UK Westminster establishment here
and all of them have got fingers in
different pies we begin with breaking
news and talks to a further NHS strikes
in England have broken up today without
an agreement they want to talk about is
productivity
productivity when our members are
working 18 hour shifts they let the
strikes go ahead over Christmas they
didn't lift the telephone or lift a
finger to get them off now the
government has formally tabled its
anti-strike laws in Parliament will in
the end cover uh six sectors but it will
be focused mainly on on blue lights as
they call it the ambulance strike plan
for tomorrow still
have minimum safety levels in place and
this cannot continue prime minister
all we're saying is that then these
Emergency Services patients should be
able to rely on a basic level of
life-saving care there's not a minimum
level of service any day because they've
broken the NHS
we can see there the debate dominated by
the NHS strikes but lots on the rail
strikes as well because of course those
union bosses uh giving evidence today
and a little earlier I spoke to the
transport secretary Mark Harper
I just want to start with the Sky News
tortoise investigation at Westminster
accounts into money in Westminster now
the SMP are calling for root and Branch
reform do you think the system needs it
no Lou I think the thing that's come out
of that to me is that all of this money
that people get is it is declared
um and it's all publicly available for
people to see and they're members of
parliament have to account for you know
where they take donations where they
earn income from outside then they have
to it's all publicly available they have
to be able to be transparent about you
know what they've taken what they've
been doing for it and that's how it
works and if they're and ultimately in
you know in our system if voters don't
like it they can boot them out and get a
new member of parliament I guess like
whatever where everyone agrees is the
need for transparency and that more
transparency has got to be a good thing
um one proposal that for example Eric
pickles the conservative peer uh chair
of this Watchdog one second jobs has
digested is that every donation should
perhaps be registered under someone's
actual name rather than a company that
people may or may not know who's behind
it I mean is that the kind of thing that
could be looked into well I'm very happy
if people want to look at some of the
detail I mean I think it is important
that people know if you know if MPS do
some outside work and that doesn't get
in the way of doing their job as an MP I
think it's important that MPS know what
their primary job is which is to
represent their constituents but if they
do something else as long as people are
clear about who's paying for it you know
and what work they're doing and we've
obviously tightened the rules up have
been tightened up on that over recent
years then I I think that's absolutely
fine and ultimately it's for MP's
constituents to look at the job they do
look at the information is declared and
make a decision at election time about
whether they want to keep them and I
guess the more information the better
yeah absolutely yeah no so I mean I
think if we look at proposals like that
those are ultimately for Parliament
rather than for government but you know
I think if people want to look at those
and bring proposals for then obviously
people will look at them in a in a you
know in an appropriate way
um let's talk strikes uh transport
Secretary of course you've had a busy
few months should we say
um now Nick Whelan the General Secretary
of the aslev train drivers union today
so that the possibility of a deal that
would of course avert strike action in
the future was Zero what would you put
it at well look I'm not going to put a
number on it but I thought you wouldn't
put zero well I thought it was a bit
unfair because since I met Mick Wheaton
I mean he made a perfectly reasonable
point when I met him which is that his
Union hadn't been given author yet and
obviously you're not in a position to
talk about it so I mean actually things
have actually moved on he's had an offer
he's in a position now where his Union
can sit down with the real delivery
Group which represents train operating
companies and talk it through talk
through reform talk through the money
and there's at least a the basis for a
conversation there so you know what I've
tried to do since I got this job was to
I met the unions I've tried to change
the tone of the conversation so that
we're coming across as more reasonable
and I made sure that
um improved reasonable offers were made
to the trade unions on behalf of their
Workforce and you know we've we've made
some progress on on network rail the
tssa their leader was one of those
giving evidence that the select
committee today and unite have settled
with network rails we've made some
progress I'm going to say you know you
mentioned the tssa I mean what the rmt
would say to that is that they didn't
have the same issue when it comes to job
losses and changes to their working
conditions it was easier for them to
strike a deal well look these are the
sorts of things that have to be thrashed
out but they're part of the offer that
have been made is partly on pay partly
on conditions but also there have been
some some guarantees now about no
compulsory redundancies
um for a period but it's for the it's
for the unions now to talk to the
employers and thrash out the detail and
I accept those details are important but
they've now got the space to do that I
get that you're trying to change the
tone to come across as reasonables and
it's non-confrontational but just a
couple of things to pick up on in what
you're saying you say you want the
unions to be neutral do you think that
they are not being neutral then no no
all I meant was this technical service
just the rmt when they put the first
deal to their members they recommended
their members reject it so under so all
we're trying to get to we we're
realistic to think they probably won't
go as far as necessarily recommending it
but we at least want them to put it to
their members and say look here's a deal
you decide what to do we're not going to
tell you what to do and let their
members make a decision based on all the
facts at the beginning you said that you
thought Mick Whelan had been unfair in
putting the chances of a deal at zero do
you frankly think that some of the union
leaders are acting in good faith are
they playing to the cameras a bit do you
think no no I I I think it's not helpful
if if either they or I personalize it I
want to focus on the substance and the
reason why I said I thought he was being
unfair was just because things have
moved on you know an offer has now been
made
um you know so that he may not like the
offer and he may want it to be more or
whatever but an offer has been made so
we have made some progress there's
something now for his Union to debate
and talk about with the train operating
company so I think we need to make some
progress I I asked you a question about
good faith because it feels to me like
the union leaders are saying that you
are not acting in good faith I just want
to have a look at what Mick lyncher the
rmt said at the committee today he
suggested you deliberately let the
strikes go ahead over Christmas he said
they let the strikes go ahead over
Christmas they didn't lift the telephone
or lift a finger to get them off he's
implying isn't he that you deliberately
let the strikes go ahead over Christmas
to try and turn public uh public opinion
against industrial action no not at all
I was very clear because I I was
interviewed by a number of media
organizations before Christmas and I was
very clear I'd facilitated offers to go
to the trade unions I wanted them to sit
down with the employers talk through
those details look at the reform package
and try and get to a solution and not
have the strikes those strikes were not
just damaging for you know the workers
that lost income but they were
enormously inconvenient for not just for
people going to work and important
appointments but the hospitality sector
for example
reckoned that it costs them about two
and a half billion pounds in Lost
Revenue so if I could have avoided the
strikes happening I would have done if I
could have done some more to do that I
would have done so but I did what I
could do which is to make sure that we
had some offers on the table for the
unions and the employers to talk about
them and I'm pleased that that's what
they're now doing and I hope that we can
make some some progress there's another
thing that I struggled to get my head
around uh frankly right is it right that
the department for transport still pays
out money to the train operating company
companies during strike action so even
if there's no service they still get
money from the taxpayer well look the
way it works Post cover it is that
effectively you know we we don't have
the franchising model anymore we have a
system where the railway companies are
paid um you know by my department to
operate the service that exists because
this person is you know if that is the
case then there's they haven't really
got any incentive to reach a deal have
they they're going to get the money
whatever happens doesn't matter to them
if they're strikes or not well they get
paid to run the service but they do they
do want to solve these problems and
ultimately I want to solve these
problems because you know your viewers
may not realize this but you know since
covert the taxpayer has put a fortune
into the railway
points the money into the railways even
if there's no training yes no absolutely
and it's wonderful but it's one of the
reasons though why we need to settle
these disputes but we have to settle
them in the way that's fair both for the
passenger who is interested in how much
their fares are and whether their trains
are reliable but also the taxpayer there
isn't a bottomless pit of taxpayers
money I'm Keen to talk to you a bit
about the NHS as well because obviously
the transport is not the only sector
where strikes are going ahead we've seen
lots of strikes in the edge as well
nurses ambulance workers as well we'll
be talking to Pat Cullen of the Royal
College of Nursing after this interview
what's your message to her well look I
think two things I think first of all in
the NHS we have a way of dealing with
pay which is through these independent
pay review bodies
um and you know the government sets out
its position the unions are able to put
evidence to them and last year's pay
review body we accepted in full so that
you've got nurses who've got at least a
1400 pound payment we we know we play
this game we play this game for months
now you know you can overrule them if
you want to can't you yeah but we have a
process on purpose so so that it isn't
just about politics so we've accepted
those pay-per-view bodies and by the way
not every government in the past has
always accepted that we've accepted
those yeah
they've tended to do less not not more
what we've done this week which we
thought was a helpful piece of
transparency and discussion with the
unions was
um the pay review body the Secretary of
the State have got paid review bodies um
wrote to the uni leaders met them to
talk about the evidence that the
government's going to put into those
pay-per-view or is to talk to you is to
understand where there may be some
common ground and to look at the what
the pay-per-view bodies are going to be
doing for the coming Financial year and
we thought that was helpful but you know
ultimately the the initial ask of the
nursing Union was a was a pay rise of
RPI plus five percent that was close on
nine days
yeah but coming up with a very large
number and then saying you'll meet
someone halfway for something that's
still an inflation busting pay rise it
isn't affordable for the tax well
they're saying that around 10 which is
around and inflation yeah but it's not
affordable for the tests
by the way than is the average in the
private sector which is more in the four
or five percent space so you know we've
got to be fair to Public Service workers
you know we value nurses which is why we
gave them a pay rise when there was a
freeze in the public sector but it's
also got to be fair for the people that
are paying their taxes in the private
sector who are getting much smaller
rights I do ask you
um you know we're seeing multiple
strikes across different sectors you
know almost every week There's a new
strike
um this is a government that or a prime
minister that is trying to model itself
as you know it's all about competence
yeah and if you can't get a grip on
these strikes you're failing to avert
them isn't that the definition of
incompetence no not at all look what
we're trying to do and the Prime
Minister set out his priorities uh last
week is about trying to halve inflation
this year now that doesn't happen
magically by itself it happens if you
take sensible policy decisions so look
the reason why there are more strikes is
very straightforward would inflation has
been high not entirely but largely
driven by Putin's war in Ukraine which
has driven up Energy prices and food
prices that's had a knock-on effect so I
completely understand why people are
feeling under pressure but the problem
is if the government then just embeds
those higher pay rises in the system
we're not going to halve inflation this
year and if we're still here next year
with high inflation we haven't helped
anybody people are struggling to you
know Heat their thumb Heat their thumb
if people are struggling to heat their
homes feed their families you hear
stories about nurses going to food food
banks they're not going to be thinking
about embedding you know payroll that's
why we look that's why we wanted to make
Fair pay Rises which is why we've
accepted in full the pay review body
recommendations that we've done that
that's also why the that we've got a
package of support for people to help
them with high energy prices so we
accept that people need help but you've
got to balance it and ultimately we want
to get to the position where we've
Harvard inflation we've driven it down
grow the economy and then people will
actually be and feel better off and I
think that's where we want to get to at
the end of this year just finally
because we are um out of time um
confirmed that he has used Private
health care in the past he won't go as a
time period so we don't know if it was
10 years ago or 10 days ago should we
care
well I think the most important thing is
whether he's doing the right thing for
the NHS and you know he comes from an
NHS family his dad was a GP his mum was
a pharmacist and I judge him by what he
does and he's put you know the Autumn
statement when we had tough decisions to
take we put a significant amount of
extra resources into Health and Social
care to deliver on the ground I guess
that's maybe where some people's concern
is though you know will he do the right
thing by the NHS if uh you know we've
seen these huge waiting times for
ambulances for a e for operations for GP
appointments people may not trust that
he's going to do the right thing if he
doesn't understand what it's like for
most people well look I think he does
and that's why if you look at his
priorities he set out last week one of
them was about those weights for
elective operations the operations that
are planned which is why we've almost
got rid of anybody who's waiting for two
years in that that post-pandemic backlog
we're hoping to get that down to uh by
by March we'll have got rid of any work
body waiting more than 18 months and
then the plan is by next spring is we'll
have got rid of anybody having to wait
for more than a year but at the same
time we're putting more resources in
place to deal with accidents and
emergency to get people out of Hospital
you don't need to be there into social
care that's why the Secretary of State
set out 500 million pounds another 250
million pounds an ounce this week so I
think you judge the government what it's
doing we're focusing on accident
emergency we're focusing on elective
recovery post pandemic and I think
that's how the Prime Minister will be
judged and he set those priorities out
clearly in his speech last week okay
thank you very much pleasure
foreign well that was the transport
secretary at Mark Carper talking to me
just a little bit earlier uh this
evening and listening to that interview
here with us now is Pat Cullen who is
the General Secretary of the Royal
College of Nursing of course whose
members are due to walk out on strike
again on this time for two days next
week thank you very much for being with
us and I know you were listening to the
trans box secretary secretary there what
did you make of what he was saying
unfortunately it came across as just the
same rhetoric which has become really
tired and certainly not moving the
discussions on
um for for our nursing staff and we are
a matter of days now before the next two
days of action and so the rhetoric has
to change they need to get around the
table and start to have negotiations
proper meaningful negotiations with me
on behalf of those nurses and you know
coming out with the same staff saying
they value nurses and again the absolute
over emphasis about their pay review
body and which seems to have become
seriously more important to them than
fixing the crisis in the Health Service
and protecting the Health Service and
actually getting a resolution to the
strike and I guess the argument that Mr
Harper was making is that the pay risers
would be unaffordable he says first
Lucas it would embed High higher pay
risers in the system so stoking
inflation and also saying that in the
private sector people are getting pay
Rises of just four to five percent so
it's unaffordable and unfair for
taxpayers well that's that's
um I'm not saying that he's not telling
the truth but
um factually that's not right we sounds
like you are saying well we we carried
out
um got independent economics to carry
economists to carry out
um a very comprehensive economic study
comparing
um pay Rises within the public sector
particularly for nurses
um against those in the private sector
and it became abundantly clear within
the report that the private sector pay
has increased significantly with
um a pay Rises and pay increases that
have certainly
um been
um at the almost looking enviously so
you think within the healthcare you
would say that he's effectively cherry
picking the figures then just looking at
the last year rather than looking back
over many years yes and I think that's
not the right thing to do in the current
crime says that we find ourselves
ourselves in
um you originally asked for a 19 rise
now you're saying that's just a starting
point so are you willing to compromise
and to come down on that then well look
I think I I'm I'm on the record for
saying that we had never put a 19
um figure on it however we did certainly
set out our policy position as five
percent above the rate of inflation
um at the time that we obviously
um agreed the policy position inflation
wasn't where it was um in the current in
the current times
um however everyone knows that the
college and myself as the general
secretary has um not just extended an
olive branch but in fact I think we've
leaned the whole Tree in at this stage
to say meet us halfway get us around a
negotiating table I'll set out my stall
for the 300 000 plus nurses that to put
part in this ballot and they can do the
same and let's let's find a way through
the current crisis that we find
ourselves in the meeting halfway would
it be fair to assume around the 10 mark
look that's what you've been reporting I
can't negotiate a certain I said time
and time again I'm not going to
negotiate on the airwaves I I can't
negotiate at a table on my own and the
only table I can negotiate at is a table
with the prime minister or with the
secretary of state and I would urge them
again a matter of days from the next
strike to please do that for every
single member of nursing staff that
absolutely deserve to be heard not
talked about on the airwaves by the
Prime Minister by the Secretary of State
but talk to them through at a table with
me they owe that to nursing but they owe
it to patients as you say strong action
just a matter of days away now we heard
the train drivers Union at saying that
the chances of a deal he would put at
zero to call off his strikes would you
put yours any higher
like every single nurse listening um to
this program now and listening over this
last month we live in optimism that's
something that at some stage that sense
will be brought to these discussions by
this government so I'm not going to sit
here and lose hope
um there's hope for the next number of
days that we can get to a table and that
we can start negotiating
um I'm in communication with the
secretary of state I'm hopeful that
um the next time him and I find
ourselves at a table that the discussion
will be will be different
um and that we will start to talk
realistically about how we can bring
things to to a conclusion you say you
have optimism is there any reason for
that optimism has anything changed the
tone the messaging or is there anything
behind it well we we certainly had
optimism after listening to the Prime
Minister over the weekend
um and a
um on that basis yes we thought look
there must be something that that can be
addressed for 22-23 pay for our nursing
staff because that's where the dispute
is
um unfortunately as as time went on
through the week we heard on on on the
media that there were some discussions
about one-off payments and a back data
payment but um those those have never
been put to me either formally or
informally but it's the wrong place to
have those discussions they owe it to
nursing staff to get around a table and
have those discussions with me formally
would are there those things I know you
don't want to negotiate on the Airways
but could you see a deal forming around
those principles
whatever is put to me needs to be
significant that's the first thing it
needs to be it needs to have long-term
thinking behind it and it needs to have
long-term investment and one-off
um ill thought through payoffs isn't
going to do this but look let's get to a
negotiating table and let's start to
really fundamentally talk about what
will resolve the strike for the for our
nursing staff so it sounds like a
one-off payment I wouldn't cut it but
how about looking at you know the next
pay-per-view 2020 2023 onwards let's get
to a table and let's let's have a
conversation understood how long could
the strikes last for until we get a
resolution for our nursing staff that so
deserve it and every single member of
our nursing profession deserves more
they deserve better and they don't
deserve to be treated like this by this
government and they are saying clearly
to me on a daily basis that this
government has turned their back on them
um a profession that carried us through
the pandemic and long before it the
nursing profession is in crisis as a
consequence of how they've been treated
we have long waiting lists the Health
Service it's well documented is in
crisis the only way to resolve the
crisis in Health Service is to actually
retain and recruit our brilliant nurses
that we have got keep them and and
recruit more in and that can only be
done by this government sitting down and
talking to me but you're saying that
you'll keep going with strong action
until you get what you want I believe
our nursing staff will
um they believe that this is their
opportunity to speak up on behalf of
their patients and try and do something
to address the Staffing levels 40 seven
thousand vacant posts in this country
alone and every single nurse coming on
duty night and day feel that but more
importantly our patients feel it so this
is our time to speak up and have our
voice heard on behalf of our patients
and that's what every nurse is trying to
do now this is a really difficult
question to ask you but I am like
interested to own your opinion on it do
you feel that the strong action is
putting lives at risk
well we heard from the Royal College of
emergency medicine but I think every
nurse knows this that there are
unnecessary deaths as a consequence of
the NHS crisis it's not our nursing
staff that are putting patients lives at
risk most certainly not and I think the
Secretary of State actually admitted
himself that on the days of strike
action the Royal College of Nursing
um delivered that action with a very
safe and steady hand and there was
nothing Reckless about how we managed to
do that we Exempted emergency and Urgent
Care Services from our strike we will
continue to do that and we will do
nothing that will add any further risk
or any further unsafe care to our
patients that's what we're about and
that's what we'll continue to do and
just finally what kind of things are
nurses seeing in the NHS right now just
give it as a sense of how you see the
state of NHS the NHS and I've been a
nurse for 42 years and I speak to it to
um our profession every single day they
would say that they it was it was
difficult during a difficult being
um a word that I'm using likely during
the pandemic but this that's nothing
like like it is it's absolutely worse
worse than June they are working in an
incredibly
um fragile critical state every single
day with a very depleted Workforce but
they themselves are emotionally
psychologically and physically depleted
having gone through two years of the
pandemic and they are working excessive
hours very very long hours and very
unsafe conditions unsafe so people are
dying unnecessarily as well well we've
heard from from the Royal College of
emergency medicine people are dying
unnecessarily and that's not the way we
want our patients to be treated it's not
how the people of this country should be
treated and we need we ought to be doing
better we ought to be doing
um delivering a Health Service that
actually is the Envy of the world but
unfortunately I believe this government
has not just let patience down and are a
profession down but actually they're
letting the NHS die thank you very much
indeed uh good to talk to you today Pat
Colin there of the rural College of
nurses always good to have you uh here
well a little later we will get Labor's
table first let's get the thoughts of
our chief political correspondent John
Craig uh shall we it's interesting isn't
it you know the interest the interview
there with Pat Cullen and other
interviews that we've done in the past
few weeks with NHS leaders
it does feel doesn't it like there is a
real concern about the state of the NHS
um what's your action to the interviews
that we've heard so far well first of
all Mr Harper was talking about a change
of tone since he became a Secretary of
State for transport and then minutes
later Pat Cullen says same old rhetoric
so uh the change of tone has made no
difference now just on Mr Harper first
of all
um I thought he was on you had him on
rather dodgy ground when you challenged
him on the fact that these train
operating companies are still getting
these subsidies from the government
despite the fact they're not running
trains
um his message clearly was that he
wanted the unions to put the he used the
word neutral a couple of times to put
the various offers to the members rather
than recommend that they reject them but
um he really and then when you moved on
to the NHS well he started trotting out
the um
prime minister's five pledges he
mentioned halving inflation a couple of
times and then he mentioned falling
waiting lists which are the Prime
Minister the Proctor of the prime
minister's five pledges so obviously we
know he was very much a soon act
supporter during the summer but uh as I
say different tone perhaps but same old
message it looks like and what was
really interesting from Pat Cullen was
that she absolutely appeared to rule out
this idea of a thousand pound bonus or
whatever the figure is she said no
that's no good I mean the labor party
would call that sticking plaster that's
a phrase we've heard from them a few
times this week from kirst armor and
where's treating
um my understanding is that was a
suggestion I think was put to Steve
Barkley by one of the other unions might
have been Eunice now I'm not entirely
sure but it looks as though that's a
non-starter and it looks also from what
we hear looks as though that the Prime
Minister and the chancellor have ruled
that anyway so here we are well in the
second week of January and we haven't
really moved on since before Christmas
yeah it does really feel doesn't it like
having the two in two interviews back
just how far apart the sides are as well
it's always nice while we have you John
to kind of like pick out some of the
moments of the week and there was a
photograph isn't it that we thought that
we would uh show I I mean it's
absolutely incredible so here's the
first photograph uh you can see there
Boris Johnson private place let's have a
quick look at the second one
where's he gone John where's he gone
Purge like Stalin did to his opponents I
mean the irony of this this is the week
this this appeared on the day that Boris
Johnson began his comeback tour with his
uh speech at the Carlton Club where they
were unveiling a portrait of him yeah I
mean Mr chaps we saw her in the House of
Commons yeah there is there's Grant so
I'll Stand Back a bit unveiling this
very controversial bill on minimum
Services took questions from MP for
about an hour and a half or a couple of
hours I think it was but uh anyway
um yeah I mean he that that's the space
rocket the one in uh um down in Cornwall
last I think that was the year or so ago
that photo but it's I mean there's a gap
it just looks ridiculous doesn't it I
mean facial distancing stuff yeah I mean
some MPS will say well this is typical
Grant shapes because he's got a bit of
form for being a bit uh well should we
say yeah careful
pain there I'm gonna I'm gonna jump in
but what a great moment of the week
um Mr champ since he was unaware of any
editing uh I'm just gonna link right
right I'm gonna walk away well we heard
from the transport secretary for the
government a little earlier and thank
you very much John uh and his shadow at
Louise Hay joins us now for Labor's take
on the ongoing strikes crisis across the
public sector and transport Network I
know you were tweeting about the grant
chaps photo earlier this week as well
thing that's ever happened you've taken
the photo down but my favorite thing was
that he actually forgot to photoshop out
Boris Johnson's elbow that was still uh
onto more uh serious uh matters uh the
rail strikes what did you make of Mark
Harper's interview I don't know if you
caught much of it well I I think it's
incredibly frustrating that here we are
six months after
um the strikes um have started this
dispute has been rumbling on for all
these months and we're still hearing
um the same old rhetoric from the
transport secretary they started when
Grant chaps was still my opposite number
and even back then when they started it
was clear to everyone in the industry
and in the public that nothing could
happen with this dispute that the
operators and network rail couldn't lift
a finger with without the transport
secretary or the treasury's influence
and these negotiations simply can't be
brought to a resolution until the
transport secretary does his job grows
up and sits down at the negotiating
table with the with the operators
because as you rightly pointed out post
covered we now have this system where
operators get a fixed fee regardless of
whether their trains run so they have
absolutely no incentive whatsoever to
settle this dispute so what exactly what
Mark Harper is doing is talking to them
right which is what Grant shops didn't
do but Mark Harper is actually now
talking to the union bosses so what
would you do differently you know if you
were the transport secretary if you were
sitting down around the table what
happened then well we've got a better
tone from Mark Harper than Grant chaps
there's no there's no doubt about that
but there's worlds apart from getting in
the unions for a cup of tea in the
department for transport and actually
sitting down and doing the hard graft of
negotiation what is what is your
starting point for my negotiations then
well the negotiation is about a whole
raft of things we've got pay we've got
conditions we've got jobs and that needs
to be done actually as part of a wider
conversation about reform in the rail
industry and that's part of the problem
that's part of the reason why the
dispute is rumbling on longer than it
should because it's happening in this
completely unreformed and quite frankly
failing rail system where operators are
being given a fee regardless of whether
their trains run and you've got a system
where the likes of Avanti and Transplant
and express are not delivering the
service that are required of them not
investing in the workforce as they have
been asked to do time and time again
over very many years and it's a a
feature and a failure of the very
short-term nature of the rail industry
so labor have a plan to bring our
Railways back into public ownership to
reform the system to put passengers back
at the heart and frankly reset
industrial relations so we can bring
this cycle of very disruptive disputes
to an end you obviously do want reform
of the nationalization project but minus
something is that would only happen when
contracts expire so will be some years
away even if labor do again into power
so I'm kind of interested in the here
and now do you think that rail fair is
too expensive right now well first have
risen far faster than uh than wages over
the last 10 years they've risen faster
than fuel as well so the rail is is
unaffordable so far too many people if
it is unaffordable then what would you
do because at the minute you know the
the people working the railways want
more money they're resisting reforms
that would for example lead to driver
operated trains which would potentially
reduce costs as well and obviously there
is this taxpayer subsidy as well that
you've raised points about so where does
the savings come if you want to make
rail fare more cheap well look there
needs to be investment in the in the
rail service it's undeniable and the
fact that that was investment through
covid to keep it going doesn't deny the
fact that um there are issues with pay
um now you know there needs to be that
wider reform and actually the vast
majority of franchises will come up in
the first for expiration in the first
first term of a labor government a lot
are already being run by the operator of
Last Resort so it's not the case that
this would be very far in the future
there needs to be that widespread
performance and the fact is the amount
that they wanted to save through the
workplace reforms that they're trying to
push through have already been far
eclipsed from the damage that these
strikes have done to the economy over
the last six months so the intransigence
and the ham-fisted approach that this
government has taken to this dispute is
costing the economy and the entire rail
industry dear
um just finally
um should we care if the prime
minister's had private healthcare
I think I mean we want the prime
minister to be honest about it which he
failed to be at the weekend and only
just corrected um today but I think what
it gets to the heart of is because the
NHS is in such crisis because we have
record waiting lists with over seven
million people waiting for Health Care
it has effectively created a two-tier
health system which means that a lot of
people can't afford can't aren't unable
to access Healthcare aren't able to
access a GP appointment and can't get
into a e and it does mean that the
well-off can afford Private health care
and if that's the case with the Prime
Minister
um then he should be honest about it and
it does reveal something that he doesn't
isn't necessarily experiencing the very
poor Healthcare that a lot of people
across the country are okay thank you
very much for being on the program uh
Lou Hague there at speaking to us you're
watching uh the take we are live in
Westminster for you this evening up next
the SMP says a Sky News special
investigation into money in politics
means there must be reform we'll bring
you our latest Special Report from the
Westminster accounts
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome back to Westminster
you're watching the take now the
Scottish national party is calling for a
complete overhaul of MPS outside
earnings and donations that's after Sky
News investigation Shone a light on
money in Westminster our Deputy
political editor Sam Coates spoke to the
party's Westminster leader Stephen Flynn
if we have for instance or for example
an MP who is receiving money from an
organization and someone cannot
immediately determine who has donated
that money to that organization that has
got turning alarm bells for everyone
alarm bells for what is the motives for
that person wanting to of that
organization wanting to give money to to
the MP what is the critical for doing so
because money isn't just given freely
let's not be Daft here
um and ultimately what we need to see in
respect of that is complete and a
complete overall of it that shouldn't be
allowed to happen
student Flynn pretty clear there and the
chair of one of westminster's Ethics
Watchdogs because Todd Sky News that the
ability of lobbying firms to influence
MPS through informal groups in
Parliament could be in his words the
next big scandal in politics now all
parliamentary all party parliamentary
groups or appgs very Snappy are groups
of MPS and peers who share an interest
the Westminster accounts project from
Sky News and tortoise media has revealed
that apbgs have received over 20 million
pounds worth of funding from external
organizations just since the last
election now the funding is legal as
long as it's declared and there is no
undue political lobbying attached our
Deputy political editor Sam Coates has
this exclusive report
Qatar welcoming the world but long
before the fans arrived came the MPS
dozens visited the country before the
World Cup and Sky News is Westminster
accounts project can reveal the Qatari
government at over 240
000 pounds in hosting them MPS insist
their visits were purely educational but
this part of a system that some say is
all about persuasion
all party parliamentary groups where MPS
from all sides can come together around
shared interests and issues they do
research make visits and publish reports
Loosely regulated they have no official
status in Parliament but they're a big
part of the Westminster system and what
they say carries weight MPS are calling
for a review of the use of so-called
smart motorways he now says he'll be
starting a new group of MPS to push that
further saw types are drugs laws British
parliamentarians are worried the Saudi
package won't meet UK travel regulations
MPS want the manufacturer to make amends
if they get us pressure being exerted on
companies who frankly have got away with
murder
huge influence in the public debate but
what happens behind closed doors whether
you're lobbying for a bank a religion or
a nation-state
appgs might not be well known but they
are big business
20 million pounds has been funneled into
them over the course of this Parliament
alone most of that goes on paying for
organizers reports research events and
trips and there are plenty of these
appgs to put money into
753 active groups that's more of them
than there are sitting members of
parliament
and these are the ones that are getting
the most money so many different
subjects covered here in just the top
five banking Christianity leveling up
Tech and artificial intelligence there's
an appg for every sector and every cause
and this is where the money is coming
from names you've probably never heard
of but what they say they do is
revealing of the top 10 six of these
companies are registered for lobbying
and many others have a clear agenda
so much of life in Westminster is
lobbying the art of persuasion Central
to politics and appgs can provide a rich
canvas it takes just five MPS to set one
up and companies can fund them directly
giving to a group that matches their
cause or they can give cash via a
lobbying group
it's their job to convince politicians
and governments to do what they want but
it's not always easy to get them to
speak on camera so when I was offered
the chance to share an event on lobbying
in Parliament I couldn't possibly say no
and we've got a brilliant panel here
tonight to talk through that a room of
lobbyists making the case that they can
be a force for good they see appgs as a
powerful tool I know rappg helps
influence
getting more money for Northern culture
and the leveling up like people are
living up from we did that we know that
with Net Zero we know the action fans uh
the 2030 Target was reduced because of
what we said we think that but it was
had influence and that's bringing that
group together it's really effective but
finding it hard to defend the system
some people worry that apbgs are used
through the secretariats and thought
that you run in order to push particular
corporate agendas
is that true
I think it might be true I think
probably
most groups do things or operate the way
we do I think there are minority of
appgs that are funded by certain
organizations who are peddling their
line
and they are trying to unfairly
influence parliamentary decisions there
are too many of them and it's too easy
to set them up where there's a potential
problem is in the lack of transparency
on funding lack of transparency on their
objectives and the lack of transparency
on how they behave within Parliament can
you name some examples or give some
scenarios where there's an issue no
why not uh no there are 650 to choose
from so but you think they're an issues
that you know that there are issues with
some of them because they're not doing
what they say on the team they're
actually tools of individual corporate
vested interests and there's no way of
stopping it don't say that do you think
there's unethical Behavior with appgs at
the moment
it's not a no I know
a start warning from one of the
government's top ethics Watchdogs season
this is the next uh big Scandal unless
we take action well a number of them are
um the Secretariat comes from
professional organizations from uh from
lobbying groups and from
organizations are a bit of glass to
grind
and I don't think there is sufficient
transparency in terms of um why they're
doing it there are clear examples of a
business putting its money into an appg
to try and influence policy the CBD appg
are funded by a single company with a
specific interest tenacious labs open
that easing cannabis regulations is the
company's goal but they say it's the MPS
who call the shots
what you have to do is you have to
persuade some MPS or officers of you
know officers there five of them that
it's of sufficient interest to them
um that if you do a bunch of grunt work
to supply them with the heavy lifting
that they're prepared to spend some time
on it and it's there appg not ours and
they make that very clear as we go along
providing them with sensible first
drafts for a discussion to happen around
and that's that's our job we work for
the appg we we don't you know we're not
the tail wagging the dog
[Music]
millions of pounds going into a largely
unregulated part of the political system
many all party groups work to inform and
educate but even those who work at the
heart of them admit they could be open
to abuse the Westminster accounts makes
it easier to follow the money
at just one of the samcoats reports
there from the Westminster accounts
project for the s p calling for reform
we wait and see if that happens
now of course the state of NHS and
Strikes across the public sector have
been a really big issue for us on the
program uh today so let's speak to our
viewers panel shall we because I'm
actually very interested to hear about
what people's experience of the health
services we often hear the worst case
stories don't we but let's find out what
people are experiencing themselves let's
go to Stella first uh shall we um Stella
Einstein had physio on the NHS recently
how was the service
can you hear us Stella uh Stella if you
can hear me I'm just asking you about
how your recent experience of the NHS
was
I think we're struggling there let's go
to islar instead let's go to ISA we'll
try and get a back to seller recently is
our now I know that you were telling our
producer Jared that some of your friends
workers Junior doctors on the NHS what
kind of thing are they telling you about
yeah I think the situation
a really extreme I think some of the
estimate even 300 people are done hey
just left the end
I think one that my friend decided
they've considered
I'm to pop
instead I think
because that controllers
kind of symptomatic system so I'm just
going to jump in because you're I I
caught bit of that but I'll be honest
the sound was dropping in and out a
little bit uh for us and but interesting
to hear what we did catch uh anyway
right let's go uh Mike shall we uh let's
hope fingers crossed that we're gonna
get like a little bit better as a panel
goes on always some technical Gremlins
around but you know we'll just ride with
it this is what the take's all about
it's fine uh Mike you use the NHS on
Christmas Eve I believe didn't you
always a busy time for the NHS what was
your experience like
in most ways it was
um
quite a long wait
opal from
timely contact
to the time I actually
scam to
diagnose what was going
but I have to say all through I'm so
sorry yeah I'm not sure what is going on
this evening and for some reason you
know the the news Gods perhaps don't
want us to talk about the NHS and by
apologies let's just try one more person
you never know we're going to get there
we're just going to go with it let's
just see Hannah hopefully fingers
crossed please uh your experience at the
NHS what do you let's hope you can we
can hear you this time
my experience with the NHS
as for the most part very good
um I was if we're good that's right I'd
say the independence
um
but they have not brought
with the independent periodic
which was essentially you know what it's
um
I think this is uh unfortunately it's
not happening for us this evening I just
want to say sorry to all of you I don't
know what is going on here
um but something tells me that four out
of six of you uh being unable to talk to
us clearly uh perhaps there was an issue
that we need to look at uh thank you
very much for showing up uh giving your
opinions as what we heard of them anyway
on the NHS thank you and apologies uh
for that apologies to the viewers as
well not quite going to plan but hey you
know don't worry we've got more John
Craig which is always a treat for us so
let's just hear a bit more from uh John
uh shall we um well we heard there
didn't we well we didn't hear I should
rather say about our viewers panel's
experience of the NHS
um I have to say John the more I talk to
people in the NHS whether it is you know
the Society of acute medicine whether
it's patcon tonight they're all saying
the same thing which is this is even
worse than the peak of the covert
pandemic and one of the problems in fact
Mr Barkley the health secretary
acknowledged this is the strain and
hospitals and a e departments is the
fact that people can't get to see a GP
now I don't know if you've rung a GP
surgery recently but
um my wife Rings the Jew who was kirst
armor at primus's questions I think
talked about Mr sunak trying to ring at
8am my wife does it and you hear on the
phone you are number 30 something in the
queue or something there was a story a
few days ago about a GP who was working
from home in Cornwall and her practice I
think was in London but she obviously
had a holiday home I mean I think one of
the things the government's got to get a
grip on is the GP service which seems to
collapse putting strain on a e
departments now the government continues
to blame Cove the pandemic obviously
there's a backlog because of that
um but it has I mean there's some horror
stories and we hear MPS in the House of
Commons Angela Rayner raised one
um yesterday I think about one of her
her constituents and we hear every day
almost some poor person who's died
because they've had to wait so long and
but now I suppose what was quite
depressing tonight was the fact that Pat
Cullen completely rejected the idea of
what some people are calling a
compromise to try and sort out the
nurse's dispute when she said no one-off
payments no good so
um
another interesting moment in the
comments this week that really caught my
my ear was that when um it was Mr
Barkley and was up against West
streeting for labor we're streating
absolutely tore into him uh during a
statement on was it Monday or Tuesday
Monday I think and then from right
behind him in the Commons chamber the
veteran Tory MP
um the Edward Lee said uh well hold on a
minute other countries have had covered
and so on he mentioned some European
countries and I think Canada was another
one as well they're not having these
problems and he says what's our plan why
haven't we got a plan we can't leave it
to the labor party said sir Edward Lee
it's really interesting isn't it because
you talked about West rooting as well
and GP surgeries and it still does feel
at the minute that it's labor who is
perhaps talking a bit more radically on
the NHS and the GP shouldn't be the only
gatekeeper for example at self-referrals
pharmacies there should be other ways of
accessing Healthcare yeah
um and and yet the prime minister
questions today Rishi sunak who I
thought actually was put in a quite a
combative performance today and he
really attacked Labor's plan said it was
uncosted and so on it's really
interesting that it does feel like that
is where the political debate is going
this year John thanks for stepping in
always great to speak to you John Craig
there on the take well that's it for
this week's uh program we will be back
next week and every week Wednesdays at 9
00 PM next up it is Sky News at 10.
thanks very much for watching
[Music]